il ya en chacun de nous quelque chose de
plus fort de plus puissant que n'importe
quelle drogue
ça s'appelle la volonté de survivre
qu'est ce que vous aimez dans la course
j'aime juste faire du vélo nous n'étions
plus cloués au sol
nous avions appris à voler c'est un
autre homme
il a survécu au cancer et il s'est
transformé en superman
pourquoi cet homme cedh à ce point et
toi pourquoi cet homme c'est pas un
ils gagneront 2
couvre d'honneur il est reçu par le
président les sponsors se bousculent
l'argent et la gloire coule à flots mais
c'est un tricheur
je suis l'athlète le plus contrôlé de la
planète je n'ai jamais été contrôlé
positif à des produits améliorant les
performances
il fait de votre petit sport européen un
événement international
s'il ment pendant les courses sait qu'il
nous ment a nous aussi
personne ne m'aura ensuite tous le
programme
j'ai pas signé pour ça il va attaquer
tous ceux qui se mettront sur son chemin
j'ai assez d'argent et de pouvoir pour
te détruire
je n'ai jamais été contrôlé positif à
des produits améliorant les performances